in the Tuscan town of Yvette's so the
local lender banker trulia collapsed
costing thousands of small investors
their holdings under the EU so-called
bail-in rule a banks creditors bear the
losses pensioner Giuseppe Landry had
bought banka trulia bonds back then they
promised over three percent interest but
now they're worthless multi management
let's so much money to companies to
friends to friends of friends millions
of euros that were never paid back it
left the bank in a miserable situation
the savers money was used improperly the
galata in the audit so offices of the
cgil trade union savers and investors
who feel cheated are getting support
they hope the country's interbank fund
will step in and compensate them the
fund guarantees deposits of up to
100,000 euros but it could take months
or even years to settle all the claims
nila wasn't most of those affected are
ordinary people workers and many
pensioners don t seem even celerity most
of them had absolutely no idea what they
were getting involved in or what kinds
of financial products they were buying a
little even Eva proposed despite
enormous pressure for change brought on
by digitization in the business reform
of the Italian banking sector is
stalling the country's financial
institutions still employ 300,000 people
at Milan's bocconi university finance
professor stefano cazale says not all
banks can be lumped together he insists
that the large lenders like unicredit
are still fundamentally sound and doing
well he says the sector needs time to
reorganize we have to cut we have two
counts a lot of branches and to cancel a
lot of branches means also to fire many
people and it's the bad side of the
story so I am much more worried about
that then they show up non-performing
loan
caselli says as many as 100,000 jobs
could be lost and the next one's to go
could also be in Tuscany home to the
world's oldest bank monte dei paschi di
siena it's sitting on billions in bad
loans and no one knows who will have to
pay for that